buenas tardes santiago qué tal estoy
aquí en la universidad del valle de cali
donde se está concentrando la minga
indígena como podéis ver detrás de mí
sin embargo todo está desierto porque
acaban de salir y más tarde nos
encontraremos con ellos y vamos a dar
seguimiento a lo que los indígenas
colombianos van a hacer al unirse a las
marchas ellos nos han argumentado que la
razón de marchar junto al resto del
pueblo colombiano es porque es cali ha
sido la resistencia de estas marchas que
empezaron el 28 de abril y además nos
han dicho que quieren lanzar un mensaje
contra la discriminación que aseguran
que están sufriendo ya que nos han
comentado algunos miembros de la minga
que el gobierno les está comparando con
un grupo guerrillero como el ejército de
liberación nacional santi más tardes
como he dicho nos reuniremos con ellos y
os contaremos más de cómo avanza la
minga
louis bueno hablando de cómo avanzará
durante la jornada de hoy contanos cómo
han sido las últimas jornadas así en
cali se han vivido episodios de
muchísima atención verdad
sí sí total la situación en cali es de
por momentos de terror no un terror que
viene causado como denuncian los
manifestantes y organizaciones
humanitarias por lo que sucede en horas
de la noche cuando la violencia policial
es que está siendo más reportada en los
vídeos de hecho siloé nosotros tuvimos
ayer el equipo de france 24 en el barrio
por la mañana mientras se realizaban
homenajes a las víctimas de la noche del
lunes que según la comunidad fueron tres
con más de 20 heridos de bala y lo que
nos contaban era precisamente eso que
cuando llega el terror es por la noche
cuando por ejemplo en la última noche
también nos han escrito para decirnos
que han cortado las comunicaciones que
cortan la luz y es lo que nos están
denunciando y también se está viendo en
reportes de las redes sociales tal y
desde el primer día ha sido el epicentro
como sabéis el 28 de abril el miércoles
pasado cuando se cumple hoy una semana
también hubo en ese caso un paro el paro
y lo que decretaron un toque de queda
desde la una del mediodía y desde ese
momento cada jornada han habido
protestas e incluso los vecinos de siloé
los más jóvenes nos decían ayer que
estaban dispuestos a resistir
incluso aunque les cueste la vida